good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences the school of data
science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical
sciences
it's my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker dr chong xi zheng
from the center of public health
genomics at the university of virginia
chongzi earned his bs in physics from p
king university in 2005 and his phd in
physics from the george washington
university in 2010.
he undertook a postdoctoral fellowship
in biostatistics and computational
biology
at the dana-farber cancer institute at
harvard university
dr zhang is an assistant professor in
the center for public health genomics at
the university of virginia school
of medicine and he holds faculty
appointments in the departments of
public health sciences biochemistry
molecular genetics and biomedical
engineering at uva
and he is also a member of the uva
cancer center
and the uva data science at the uva
school of data science
chongzi is a computational biologist
with expertise in cancer epigenomics
his research focuses on algorithm
development for high throughput genomic
data analytics and integrative modeling
of gene regulatory networks in mammalian
cell systems
he and his laboratory are developing
computational and statistical methods
for analyzing high throughput data from
innovative omics
technologies and using integrative data
science approaches
to study gene regulation in mammalian
cell systems
he developed several several popular
computational tools for chip seek data
analysis transcriptional regulatory
inference and multi-omics data
integration dr zhang's lecture today is
entitled integrative data science
approaches for studying transcriptional
regulation in the genome
and as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
youtube
if you are watching on youtube thank you
so much for joining us also our
specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr zhang via the chat feature in
their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome chongzi thank you
so much for doing this
we really look forward to your lecture
all right thank you so much jack for the
very nice introduction
um so at the beginning i wanted to share
with you that
i am actually an alumni from the 2018
cohorts of the biomedical data science
innovation lab
um this is our good picture from taken
from a beautiful resort in band
oregon it was an extremely fun
experience i benefit a lot from it
and also receive the most
gorgeous portrait of myself drawn by a
fellow
participant so i look really look
forward to seeing each and every one of
you
this year's participant in
charlottesville
uh in a couple of months so
uh today i'm going to share with you
about my research
on computational approaches and data
science approaches for studying
transcriptional regulation
genome-wide so first of all i would like
to
echo dr don brown's lecture from
earlier this in this seminar series
about what is data science
of course data science is an
interdisciplinary field of research
it lies in the intersection between the
three areas
um so i changed this picture a little
bit
specific to biomedical data science
so the the three areas uh that
form the foundation of biomedical data
science includes uh myofan statistics
which is the quantitative science basis
and computation computer science and
information technology
is the tool and engineering power for
data science
and of course we we have the important
domain knowledge and as a subject of
research and
the ultimate goal of doing all of the
data science research and in this
particular context is the biology and
biomedical sciences
so data scientists require training and
skills
in all the three areas nowadays
although most people who are doing data
science research are usually from one of
the three
backgrounds we usually need some
knowledge and some understanding of all
three areas
especially biomedical
sciences as this is where the ultimate
problem and the solution
are located um
so a another way of understanding data
science
is to start from data
and using computational other
quantitative approaches to convert the
data into
information and connect them into
knowledge
and to look for insights and eventually
look for new
biology or new science from this data
and information
so every step in this process
is involves new methods and eventually
we are going to our goal is to make
scientific discoveries from this data so
data science is the combination of data
and innovative computational
modeling and meanwhile
where we also need to pay attention to
the data problem since
they easily have overfitting and
over-interpretation
issues that we want to pay attention in
the uh
data science research
so i want to share with you um a uh a
blog piece from my postdoc mentor
shirley liu
uh who she wrote this in a few a few
years ago about levels of bioinformatics
research
i think it also applies to the general
biomedical data science research very
well
so there are different levels of the
research
and just like if you uh have watched uh
kung fu panda a few years ago that would
start from the level zero
um level zero is not uh
the type of the type of work that we
actually recommend
is so-called modeling for modeling sake
um
as this is as if you only have a hammer
and you are looking for a nail
nails everywhere and and this you
need to get lost from this uh approaches
since you are not
focusing on this particular biomedical
uh
problem and then the level one is to
apply
existing software tools to analyze new
data
and to make new novel findings so this
is a start level of
uh uh bioinformatics research
they focus on the particular biologic
biology problem
and it's important to pick the right
tool to do the
job correctly and this is also a good
training at the start point of
biomedical data science research
and for level two is to develop
new methods uh for general data science
problem
uh focusing on the research area um
the important thing is that the the
tools and the methods
or models should be useful uh to the
field to the to the study of a
particular problem or to analyze
one type of type of data from a new
technology
and um they should advance the knowledge
in this area
and they should be able to to be used by
other people in this field
and level three is to integrate in
existing big data in a smart way to make
new biological discoveries so this is uh
really requires a higher level of
training and skills because the data is
there and the data are usually generated
by others
and usually the data from multiple
different sources
and the key is to use a right and smart
way to integrate
uh the data and to to make new findings
that
cannot be seen by only looking at the
one data sets
and of course the the the ultimate goal
is still to make new biological findings
and uh lastly is the level x it's the
senior level
uh to make a bigger impact in the field
is to provide
key integration and modeling to massive
data from
usually from big consortium or team
science team science efforts and this
type of work usually
includes the integration of all levels
from one to three
so i i believe that successful data
science research or biomedical
data science research is probably doing
all levels three one two three type of
work with the option and
opportunities to do some level x work
so after a brief introduction i want to
share you
uh two stories uh of the
research work that my lab is recently
doing one story
is a categorized as a level two work is
to develop computational methods
uh for transcriptional regulator
analysis and
the other story is a so-called level
three work
is we use the publicly available data to
study a transcription factor ctcf
this pattern in the cancer genome
so recently we celebrated the 20 years
anniversary of the publication of the
draft human genome sequence
the completion of the human genome
project did not mean that the effort of
cracking the genetic code was done
on the contrary it only marked the start
of the modern
modern genomics research
one of the most significant
technological breakthroughs
in the entire biomedical field in the
past 20 years
in my opinion is the development of high
throughput dna sequencing techniques
sequencing cost has dropped by over 1
million fold
since the human genome project dna
sequencing technologies was not only
used
for sequencing the the genome the human
genome itself
but it has become a positioning or a
profiling tool to study many different
elements and factors
associated with the genome and the
genomics has been
involved to to the question solving the
question of tackle
how the genome works dynamically in
different conditions
and how this genome can create such a
diverse cellular
phenotypes
we in eukaryotic cell nucleus the
genomic dna
is sophisticatedly packaged into the
structure of chromatin
a number of protein factors including
histones
with modifications
and transcription factor proteins that
interacting with dna
and other chromatin remodelers
they all have the function of regulate
the gene
transcription or gene expression and the
gene expression pattern
uh in a specific cell defines the cell
identity so the high throughput
sequencing technologies
can help measuring the genomic patterns
of
all of these information in the genome
for example the transcription level can
be directly measured by rna-seq
by measuring the rna transcript that
generated
through the process of transcription and
the uh
protein factors including transcription
factors and histomodifications can be
measured by chipset
that usually marks uh the regulated
regions
across the genome and in if we don't
know what
particular factors to chip in the cell
systems we can measure the entire open
chromatin
by dna-seq or ataxic
and those enrich the region from the
data covers most regulatory
elements regardless of what specific
protein factor
interacts there and for both chipseq and
dna's ataxia technologies they mark the
regulator
elements not only in the uh promoter
regions that are
nearby uh from a gene gene locus but uh
there are a lot of
more are enhancer like elements that are
this
uh in the distance from the gene itself
uh it's worth noting that uh the most
regulation events in human mouse systems
are at
these distal enhancer elements and the
protein coding genes sequence
only covers about 2 of the human genome
and 98 of the genome are non-coding
including those elements for regulatory
regulation for gene expression
and the chromatin structure so
the existing identified
the existing identified regulatory
elements might cover about 15 to 20
percent of the genome if not more
so as i just mentioned the chipseq and
dna syntax
they can measure the genome-wide
regulatory profiles
of some factors across the genome
and uh for chipseek it's it's measuring
dna associating factors
and for uh uh dnase and the toxic
they measure the open chromatin profiles
and they they all use different
uh biomed biochemical assays plus and
the high throughput
sequencing technologies so using the
advanced
emerging technology we can
generate a large amount of data from
this uh
that that capture the information from
different elements in the genome
that eventually regards the data and to
visualize the data in in
a certain way in across the genome and
an important work important role of
computational analysis or data science
research
is to decode these data is to
to convert this data back and to
to retrieve the actual biological
meaningful information
even from the data to find a new biology
that
that is currently unknown so
my lab develops computational methods
and use this data science approaches to
study
transcription so there are two main
types of projects that are
that are going on in my lab we
classified it as a level two and level
three works are
method development and the data-driven
discovery to
identify new biology for method
development for this part
methods there are different levels of
methods in my opinion um
so one uh so there there are model
type of methods and in this context the
model means
um statistical models or math
mathematical or even physics models
including machine learning
models so these are the basic
quantitative models that can
tell the connections and the relations
of different elements from the data
and on top of the model levels there are
computational algorithms
uh that we can implement these models
to to make it happen and then on top of
the algorithm level
there are we need also develop software
tools
so that the entire community and other
researchers
can use these tools and the models or
algorithms we developed for their own
research
so we will first share with you the
first story
um a method development story about
a computational method we name it as
part
and you will know what it stands for in
a minute
for transcriptional regulatory analysis
so um as we know gene expression
determines the cell identity
and the uh regulation of gene expression
is important
topics in molecular genomics and
genetics research
so gene expression profile or
transcriptome profile can be measured by
uh high throughput technologies like
microarray and more recently
the rna-seq and even single cell rna
experiments a common practice of
doing rna-seq or gene expression
analysis is
further to identify the differentially
differentially regulated genes from
a experimental system we compare the
control and the treated or different
conditions
and these groups of upregulated genes
were done regular genes are
sharing the differential expression
pattern
and in other cases we can use
unsupervised classroom approaches to
identify
clusters of genes that are co-expressed
among different conditions
this can be a large group of
samples or even different clusters from
a single cell
uh analysis single cell data
that means these uh each different
cluster
each different groups or conditions
might refer to different cell types
and each class of genes may represent
the genes that are specifically
expressed
or active or regulated in a particular
group of cells so after identified
these gene sets that share the
expression pattern a common question we
want to address is that
what transcription factors regulate such
a gene set
with similar gene expression patterns
there are some common types of
approaches to address this
issue and all of them they will also
they will all have some
uh limitations uh for the for these
existing approaches
so first and uh foremost is the ontology
gene ontology based methods we there are
a lot of
databases like gene set enrichment
analysis or genetology
that you can characterize the
function of a group of genes but these
this is of course limited by the
existing database and
the second type of method is a
co-expression-based method
in which we use the uh
clustering and the network type of
analysis to infer the regulatory
directions in the regulatory networks
that usually only depends on the gene
expression data but
the expression of a regulatory factor
does not always
means the regulatory activity of that
factor
and the third types of method is dna
sequence motif based method
uh in in which we what we usually do
is to look for the regulatory regions
usually in the gene promoter regions
and to scan for the uh uh
highly represented uh sequence patterns
uh what we call dna uh sequence motifs
and these sequence motifs may give us
some information of what
specific uh dna sequence specific
transcription factors
are bind at these places to regulate the
gene
but the occurrence of a dna sequence
motif
does not necessarily mean that the
transcription factor is by
transcription factor binds there and
in the human mouse and high water
organisms most of transcription
factors binds at distal enhancer regions
which are difficult to identify
from the beginning and also it's
difficult to associate
these distal elements to their target
genes as it's possible that
multiple enhancers can regulate in the
same gene
in the same or different context and
and one enhancer can also regulate
multiple target genes
so uh our the rationale of
our approach the approach we develop
is to make use of existing
chipseq data which provides the direct
binding information of transcription
factors in
a lot of different cell conditions and
systems
so since the development of chipseek
technology
in 2007 there are
increasing amount of cheapsick data that
are
being been becoming available in the
public domain
and then the numbers are also
growing a lot and
i want to mention here that we we
probably heard that most of the uh most
many of the publicly available data are
generated from the large
uh consortium like the encode project
or world map epigenome consortium
but in fact the data that are generated
from this consort here
are only consists of less than 10 to 20
percent
of all the data that are available in
the public domain there are
thousands of labs are generating their
own individual data that are also
available
so this this is there this is actually a
much richer
data resource uh than we thought
so uh and this plot also shows the
increase of different types of
histomodification histomarks
chipseek data available and
in in this particular project we take
advantage of
several types of sequencing data
that includes we want to use the uh
identify where are the regulatory
regions or possible enhancers in this
case we use the dna seek data
since this is from a few years ago and
there are
over 500 datasets from different
dnac from different cell types as in
recent years a taxi has become a more
popular approach
forced to profile accessible chromatin
and taxi data may
maybe may have even more data shortly or
or probably already there are more than
a dna-seq
and uh a second type of data we use is
to quantify the enhancer activity is the
chipseq data for one type
of histone modification h3 uh lysine 27
acetylation k27 saturation data and
because this uh histomodification
marks the activity of active enhancers
from other uh histomic histomarks
and from this part you can see the the
amount of h3k27
acceleration data are increasing faster
than some other histomarks probably
because people are becomes more
interested in this
factor that that regulates the enhancer
regulator activity
and we also have collected over tens of
thousands of
chipset data for over 900 different
transcription factors
and these are the data we want to use so
our strategy
this method is to uh they are two-step
strategy uh in this method
we name the bart which stands for
binding analysis
for regulation of transcription so the
two set uh the first
step in this strategy is we give give a
genset as input
we first wanted to use the dnac data and
the hpk27
chipseek data to infer a
genome-wide cis regulatory profile that
mark the active
enhancers that could regulate
the gene sets and the second step in
this strategy
is to integrate this inferred
cis regulator profile with the over 13
000
data sets for transcription factors to
uh
identify what transcription factors are
binds at binding at these enhancer
regions that eventually regulates
the gene sets so uh
the first step of the regulatory profile
inference
uh we in the first version we take
advantage of an uh
an earlier model that we we developed
name the march that we always love to
give
fun names to the tools and models we
develop and
the idea is to convert the
uh hundreds of or over a thousand h3k27
chipset data from different cell types
and different conditions
um and to to give a quantitative measure
of the regulator potentials on each gene
and then use a regression approach
to do a feature selection and to select
the informative
uh samples that can capture the
regulatory profiles that are specific
to the input gene sets we are interested
as compared to the other genes in the
genome that we are not interested
so in fact later on we updated
this method uh with a different
regression approach using adaptive lasso
and the this new updates is actually the
idea come from our discussion
uh at the biomedical data science
innovation lab a few years ago
with a fellow participants in the in the
innovation lab
professor yang chen who is a
statistician from university of michigan
she suggested that uh adaptive lasso
might be a better approach
of uh addressing this and indeed we
updated
this uh method uh in our recent
new version of bart
and the second step is to
associate the inferred cis regulator
profile with the tens of thousands of
chipseq data
and to identify which data sets and
which transcription factor
that have the binding profile that are
most associated were most
similar to the cis regulator profile
and we use several additional steps of
integration
and remove some background and to get
and add additional levels of history
tests to give a
integrative rank of all the
transcription factors that have chipset
data
and eventually we will make the
prediction by
saying that the highly ranked
transcription factors from the other
from the entire list
are are predicted or inferred to be the
most likely transcription factors that
regulate the target gene sets
and uh we compare some of the
existing methods for uh for the
transcription factor
inference some of them are using the
motif based approach including homer
and some others are also use similar
chipseq database
approaches to evaluate the performance
of these different
methods um the evaluation is done
in data from a database called noctf in
which they contains
the genius differential expression data
from a knockdown or
knockout of some transcription factors
and we say if we don't know what the
transcription factor it is
if we only fit in the uh their
differential expressed genes whether we
can
correctly predict the true regulator
that was
knocked down to generate that data sets
and
in they include the database includes
over 500 data sets for about
over 300 different transcription factors
and for both the data data sets number
of data set level and
the number of factors level uh the our
new version of bart
in the web version called our web uh
outperforms uh
several other existing methods also
outperform our our own
earlier version of bart in identifying
the true factor from the knockdown data
sets
then we also thought about if this tool
can
infer the transcription factor that are
associated with
any a regulator profile it may be also
be able to apply it to other type of
genomic data
if we also want to be interested in the
transform factor
association so uh
recently we developed a a variant
version
of this uh of bart we named the bar 3d
3d means the 3d genome data and the goal
is to identify the transcription
regulators
or transcription factors that are
associated with differential
chromatin interaction from a
differential high c data analysis so
high c measures the
uh chromatin interaction across the
genome
that can help us build up the entire
three dimensional structure of the
of the uh genome and chromatin structure
by comparing uh two high c maps
the goal here is to first identify the
genomic regions
that have a differential different level
of interaction with their nearby regions
within a certain distance boundary and
then
to infer the transcription regulators
that are associated with this
differential chromatin interaction
profile
so then we test this method and it looks
like it works well
um identifying the right transcription
factors that are knocked down
from the from the either the knockdown
or deletion of transmission factors
um the uh
knock down the transform factors and the
high cd that generated afterwards
and uh we found that the bar 3d can not
only identify the factors
uh that were that were knocked down or
knocked out
but they also identified some other
interesting factors
that are either can be proved uh were
needed further validation to be also
play a role in this process
of changing the uh chromatin
conformation
structure so
as a result we integrate all of these
several tools
uh we developed into a large system
including a web
server that can provide the analysis
by any user even for a non
computational biologist once you get
your gene set you can simply do the
analysis from uh
from this web server yourself
so this uh bart's tool can accept a
multiple type of
uh inputs include a gene list uh that
was designed
in the beginning and they also be a
chipseq profile if you want to identify
what other cofactors or
other factors that are close to this
chipseq profile or even a taxi profile
and it it can also accept any region
from the genome and
they can tell you what factors binds
there more likely than another method
and
high c hi-c maps
use the bar 3d approach
so
[Music]
so we hope that this tool can provide a
alternative or complementary approaches
to other existing
methods like including dna motif
scan so hope these two can help your
studies of the functional regulators to
explain or interpret
your differential gene expression uh
data or and
or other type of genomic profiling data
so then we we want to look for the uh
somehow find some application of the bar
to ourselves
so one effort that we did recently
is to uh predict the active
transcription factors
in a cancer type using the existing
cancer transcriptome providing data from
the cancer genome atlas
or tcga because of the limitation of the
availability of
primary tumor samples
tcga does not provide any chipset data
that measures the actual
actual regulatory profile
from this from this cancer patient
but tcga has rna-seq data
measuring gene expression so for each
and every cancer type
we simply did a different did a
differential expression analysis to
identify
the cancer comparing the cancer samples
with
the normal samples to identify the
differentially expressed genes
up regular genes in cancer and
downregulated genes in cancer
and then run the bart analysis to to
take to integrate the information that
we
we we have from the bart from the
large amount of data from the public
domain to use the public data to infer
the possible transcription regulators
transform factors
that plays a role in the uh
cancer gene regulation and this is
actually done
by a very talented undergraduate student
in my lab zach thomas
and he processed all of the data from
tcga and
display this data to the public domain
in a data database as a resource
and in in this way we can
browse or look for the activity of each
and every transcription factors
in in the that are that have chipset
data
so for example if we look at uh
the pattern the tf activity pattern of
one transcription factor
in this plot we are plotting this uh
part
a prediction score for for for this
factor
for in each and every cancer type and we
also compare
to a earlier uh
another similar uh approach that using a
different
similar work but using a different
approach to infer the
transcription factor from cancer and
that's a work
from a cis from cancer database and by
integrating these two
elements it also included the including
the expression level of the
transcription factor itself
we can see that if this
this is a big circle in the top right
which means that they have a high score
in both measurement as well as a high
expression
uh level of this factor in a colorectal
cancer type
which means that this transcription
factor may play a role
in this cancer type that so this can be
useful
uh in the study of each and every cancer
type and
useful for study the activities for each
transcription factor and we are very
happy to
uh share with you that after the
publication of this
uh methods there are there are other
labs
who are using our tool bar tool to find
the important
transcription factors in different
cancer systems and they
have a very good public work
publications in
including nature and another work in uh
this is from another lab
at uva uh uh studied uh
geoblastoma and this work actually got
a semi-finalist in the recent stat
madness competition
and we are very excited that uh the
computational tools that we developed
can help other biologists
in their studies so as a quick summary
for
story one we developed this tool called
bart
it's a regulatory factor transcription
regulator identification method
and we leverage a large collection of
publicly convertible
chipset data to build the model and they
can be applied for analyzing multiple
type of data
and eventually we developed
open source software tools and web
servers and database resources
uh with application to cancer research
hope that
these tools can be helpful uh for
any researcher who are interested in the
transcription regulation as well
and next i'll use a few minutes to share
my second story level three
data-driven discovery star story about
the city cell pattern in the cancer
genome as i mentioned briefly that
the genomic dna is organized into in a
hierarchical chromatin structure in the
eukaryotic eukaryotic cell nucleus
and the three-dimensional uh
hierarchical structure
includes the multi-megabases size the
compartment
a b compartment and hundreds to
megabases
100kb or to megabases size the
topological associating domains
or tags and numerous smaller
chromatin loops so ctcf
is a protein dna binding
protein or also categorized as a
transcription factor
that binds in the dna and they can
it can induce dna looping with cohesion
complex and other proteins
such as mediators it binds at most
test domain boundary regions and has an
important function in maintaining the
chromatin structure
and the higher water topology so cdcf
as a transcription factor is is the very
factor that connects
the local level transcription regulation
and
the larger scale chromatin structure so
that's why we're
specifically interested in the pattern
and behavior of this transcription
factor
and we found that city cell binding is
usually very stable and conserved
across different cell types in the human
genome this is
expected because they it bounced to
maintain the
relative state stable chromatin
chromatin structure so we compare uh
the quantity accessibility profile from
uh
dozens of cell types from the encode
consortium
and uh we found that the variation of
chromatin openness at city cell binding
size is actually the smallest
as compared to uh the other
non-promoter or enhancer regions and the
promoter regions
so for such a stably bind protein a
disruption of cd cell binding size can
be very dangerous to the
dangers to the cell it can change the
chromatin conformation
and interactions that alter the gene
expression
pattern so existing works
usually attribute the cd cell binding
alterations
to dna sequence mutations and the dna
methylation changes
as many individual cases have been found
in the cancer and developmental diseases
however we wanted to take a look at the
bigger picture view of the cdcf binding
landscape
and look for general pattern of city
cell binding alteration in the whole
genome
and the different cell types
city cell binding can be measured by
chipseek across all different
cell types we collected over 800 public
available chipset data
from hundreds of human cell types
including both normal tissues and
disease including cancer
cells from this snapshot we can see that
across different cell types
some binding sites are very conserved
and some other binding sites
are specific to several cell types
so we kept over 700 data sets
that are have high quality and merge all
the
bindings identify binding sites um
together
in and generated a whole repertoire of
uh possible city cell binding sites in
the genome that includes
that have over 600 thousands of unique
regions in the genome that can have city
cell binding in any
uh cell type and then we look at
the for each binding size we look at the
occupancy score meaning that how many of
the
data sets where there is a peak
at this region and then we look at the
distribution of these occupancy scores
for all the city cell binding sets we
can see that the majority of the binding
sites are specific
to a field data sets they are cell type
specific binding sites
where on the other side of this curve we
observe an elevated tail
there is a group of binding sites that
are stably occur
in almost all data sets uh
imagine a background where city cell
binds randomly
at different sites in different cell
types the expectation of observing a
peak
binding sites with certain
occupancy scores should decrease
drastically when the occupancy score
increases
then we use a parallel function to model
this background and we can see the
number of conserved the size are
much greater than expected by chance so
we define these
group of binding sites or constitutive
binding sites and they are
the group of binding that are marked at
topological associated domain boundary
regions
now once we have all the c cell binding
in the human genome we want to know if
there are
any binding sites that are specific to
one cell type
and in this context we are interested in
a cancer
and we use one cancer type t-cell acu
lymphoblastic leukemia
as an example to show our approach
in our collection we have eight chipseq
data sets
from the tll cell lines and we compare
the reg
the occupancy score of all the over 600
thousands binding sites in the genome
and plot this distribution
according to their occupancy score
in the eight tll
data sets whereas the occupancy
frequency in
all the other uh 763 data sets
so the the the for each elements uh the
dance
represents the number of uh chipset
binding sites that belongs to this group
so we are specifically interested in two
groups of city cell binding events
one group is that the constitutive
binding site
which means that they are conserved in
most
uh cell types the binds there but
specifically lost in tll
um has a very low occupancy score in tll
and whereas the we define this group as
a putative lost site
and on the other uh side we defined
another group as putative gain set which
means that they are very cell type
specific they don't bind in most
cell types but very conserved
conservatively
bind in the t cell leukemia data sets
and we also make sure that these for for
cancer studies we also make sure that
these
gain and loss are indeed uh have
different level
comparing the cancer versus their match
the normal cell type to make sure that
they are indeed cancer specific not
but not only cell type specific using
using the similar approach
uh we we can we are able to identify
such
uh binding gain and binding loss
in every cancer type that have enough
available data
including leukemia breast cancer
colorectal cancer lung
and prostate cancer so because most of
the existing chipset data are generated
from cell line models
we want to make sure that this binding
size actually occurred
in the actual cancer primary
tumor patient cancer patient data so not
artifact from the cell line but uh as we
know most
we don't have uh cheap sequence data for
cdsf
for most cancer patients but we know
that the chromatin accessibility
are positively correlated with the city
cell binding so we take advantage of the
available toxic data from the tcga to
see
if the city cell binding loss again also
potentially
occur in patients so the idea is that
we identified those uh again inside and
we look at
their differential quantity
accessibility levels comparing
in the cancer and the other the other
samples uh
in as control indeed we found that these
identified cancer specific again
loss events show a different
differential level
of quantity accessibility in the primary
patient samples
that indicates that this unique loss
organ city cell binding events
are not only from cell line but also
occurred in primary cancer
so then we wanted to ask whether these
specific binding events correlate with
other features in the genome
so use the our developed
by 3d approaches that can measure the
differential quantity
level we found that the gain and the
loss
of citizen binding
positive associated with the gain and
the loss of chromatin
while the elevated or decreased
chromatin associating
interaction levels uh comparing the
cancer and the normal cell type
and um we also found that uh
as previous studied the
loss of cdcf binding
largely correlated with the increase of
dna methylation at the binding sites
also using the public available dna
methylation profiling data
but interestingly we found that the dna
methylation
again of dna methylation for loss of
binding but the loss of dna methylation
can only explain
only a portion of the again the city
cell binding
they don't explain most of them um so
now we wonder
why uh are those uh
binding sites specifically gained in
this cancer type
whether there are other factors that
could induce this event so from the
gender
binding sites we identified we first did
a motif scan but we did not find any
other interesting motif other than the
city cell motif itself
and then we look further in across the
genome by using the high c data
and we look at the regions that have an
increase in interaction
with again the cdcl sites and then did
use the bart the tool here here comes
the application of the bar 2 to identify
what possible transcription factors are
enriched
in these regions and interestingly we
found several
transcription factors that are known to
be the oncogenic transcription factor in
this specific cancer type
uh with the help of our instrumental
collaborators we validate our prediction
or to study what's the role of this
transcription factor
namely notch in the
in the occurrence of a city cell
binding sites that are specific in this
cancer type so
we perturb the notch by creating a notch
off and not
on states using a gamma sequence
inhibitor
and to remove this inhibitor and once
the notch binding is removed and
and and regained we wanted to see
whether the identified again the cities
have
also changed and indeed we found that
after
knowledge is removed most of the gang
the city cell binding decreased
and after knowledge is rebound
most of the decreased city cell binding
regained their binding in in the in the
cancer site
this means that um the perturbation of
this
transcription factor can result in the
change
of the city cell binding on the other
hand we want to address
whether the gain binding city of cdcf is
required
for the transcription regulatory role of
the notch the transcription
factor in this cancer type so we knock
down
cdcf using shrna and
generated the rna-seq data
to look at the expression and
if we use bart to identify the possible
regulators for the
differentially expressed genes after
citizen have knocked down the top
in which the factor are actually not
which means that
once you knock down cdcf notch target
genes
are downregulated as also shown using a
privately identified
large target gensets this means that
indeed
cdcf binding is required for the
oncogenic notch
to activate their notch target genes
so although we did not observe a direct
protein protein interaction
uh between cdcf and the notch
um so we uh so so this this process is
probably not
a conventional recruit protein
recruitment
from one to another so we further
proposed a model this largely still
speculative
and as a hypothesis that can be tested
further
that we we found that uh our well i mean
our uh
uh idea is that the function of
knowledge a
function of cdsf in this particular
cancer cases is to
facilitate the formation of a
transcriptional condensate
with the super-enhancer regions for
transcriptional activation so notch can
be recruited
by this large condensed transcriptional
condensate
induced by some transcription factors
including notch
that that is known to induce silver
enhancers
with other cofactors and chromatin
remodelers
to create this very active uh
transcriptional activation stat
status to to make the transcription
happen
so as in summary for the second story
we use the integration approach
and take advantage of over 800 publicly
available chipset data and also
integrated
with other genomic data most of them are
available from the public domain
and we found the interesting pattern of
cdcf
binding in the genome of cancer cells
and
we we found that dna mutations or dna
methylations cannot
explain most of the cities uh
cancer-specific gand
or lost city cell binding events
we observed in cancer and
possibly the cancer-specific gandicity
cell binding
has a role of facilitating the oncogenic
transcription activation by contributing
to the formation
of transcriptional condensates with
super enhancers
so by sharing with you these two stories
i hope
um we well i've
convinced you that our approach of doing
data science in genomic research
and using data science innovative data
science approaches
we can change the olmics studies
that were criticized you used to be
criticized by
cindy brenner a long time ago as
low input high throughput no output
but become but change this to a real
precision science
for position medicine research so
last i would like to thank
the people who actually do did the work
um
my lab members and especially my postdoc
zhen zhaowang and my former student
benji ma and the current undergrad
students
zac thomas who did most of the works for
developing bard
bio3d and the bar cancer resources
and zhenya wang also did all of the work
for the in the uh citizen
study and also i want to thank
my collaborators uh including uh
a panel since their crystals from
northwestern who helped us the
experimental part of the cdcf
project and yangchen that i mentioned we
met at the biomedical data science
innovation lab and
she gave us important ideas of improving
bart
as well as other collaborators and my
funding agencies and i want to mention
that
we receive the support from the jktg
foundation
as a as a seed award
as an outcome from the data science
innovation lab that
helps the development of this research
um all right so this picture was taken
uh before the pandemic and we really
hope that this can
we can get this pandemic over with
pretty soon we can meet
each and every with you in person very
soon
with that uh thank you very much for
your attention i'd like to answer
your questions you have any questions
you may have
zhang zee thank you so much that is a
fantastic amount of work
uh really what you're doing there with
these computationally intensive
techniques for looking at transcriptome
factors is uh
really quite amazing and it's fantastic
that you have these resources that
you've built
um like bartcancer.org in places where
people can actually take their own data
or data that's publicly available and
analyze it just a couple of questions
for you
how speaking of computationally
intensive how computationally intensive
are these types of analyses
and and how do you do it do you do it on
local machinery and
in your laboratory or could one do it on
local machinery or do you have to use
large-scale high-performance computing
or cloud computing
what do you recommend good question
so um
most of the work that we are doing is
using high performance computing
that are available to us in the from
from from uva
and some of the basic analysis of the
data
can be done uh using a local computer
but i would highly
recommend using high performance
computing to for for all the model
model building and model training a lot
of these type of work
um they may be too too intensive for a
laptop um so this
this is actually our the motivation of
for us to create a
such a web server for the uh for the
general users to use
uh uh the tools because uh not everyone
is uh
uh have has access to this
high performance computing resources and
we want to make the
the tools uh as accessible as possible
so
the the the web server we build up
connects it has a front end of a web
server but
connects to the high performance
computing in the background
so when when the actual user submitted
the job to the web browser
web server they actually the hbc will do
the computing for them
and generate the results to the users in
a fairly
small amount of time and i want to say
that this is this is after
a large amount of work of model training
and the data cleaning up so that takes
some may perhaps take more time so we
already
compress the data into a form that will
only require the
minimum amount of hpc resource
are there any special things that people
would need to know
in order to kind of get started using
these tools or is there any
any specific data science they need to
know
yeah well um as i briefly mentioned in
the beginning
um in order to understand how
how the tools work uh the only
one only need to understand the basic uh
statistics and some machine learning um
that's that's all
they need but if we simply want to know
the get the results
from a data for analyzing your data
we our goal is to to make it uh
anyone can use so even if you you don't
know any
data science you don't have any data
science background but
you have the specific biology question
you have the data
and you can generate the results
yourself
of course understanding the background
will be helpful for interp
data interpretation but that not that's
not
specifically required for using the tool
itself
chongzi zhang from the center for public
health genomics at the university of
virginia thank you so much
chung zee really appreciate you sharing
your amazing amount of work with us and
telling us about these tools and
fortunately for me i don't have to
understand any of it i can just start
going to use it
i hope that others find them also
equally uh useful for their work um
thank you again chong xi everyone have a
wonderful weekend
and we will see you all next week thanks
again bye-bye
thank you very much jack and thanks
everyone for your attention bye-bye